better
all right I had your drink now I watch
YouTube I know
free
now while you may think that if the
policeman thoughts he would reanimate I
mean I'll throw away is a cartoon
the reality is for humans and many
species freezing is lethal
the formation of ice crystals within a
cell can rupture the cell membrane
destroying the cell's function and
tissue integrity
so why are people interested in freezing
as a way of life preservation
well it is super cool for two reasons it
is well super cool in terms of
temperature and cool for the ingenious
ways researchers have found to alleviate
Ice Crystal formation which has many
potential applications this is the field
of cryobiology and query preservation
so in this video we will have a
beginner's intro to cryobiology and also
best into cryogenics the why the What
the how the what if and the potential
so firstly what is the motivation why we
need cryobiology
now while you might initially think of
something like cryogenics the
preservation of human bodies cryo
preservation more generally refers to
the process of storing materials at
sub-serie temperatures with minimal loss
and function and it's already used in
many applications but could do with some
improvements
firstly one of the motivations is for
organ transplants you're probably well
aware that there is currently a huge
shortage for organs with around 17
people in the U.S dying every day
waiting for a transplant and this number
is only expected to grow as the
population increases and gets older
cry preservation is also important for
storing cells like oocytes and sperm
which can be used to preserve one's
fertility
and similarly for scientific research
our scientists like to grow cells and
use tissue samples and we can't do
everything everywhere all at once we
routinely freeze our samples
so that we can use them at later time
points when we have time
moreover we can order cells from
so-called cell Banks and there are also
seed banks millions of seeds are being
frozen in Norway as a source of future
food and crop security there are also
cell based therapies such as
immunotherapies that are being
investigated
that also needs to be stored
and then lastly as we'll discuss now at
the end of this video there's cryogenics
the ability to preserve human bodies
when there is currently no cure to the
cause of death so that they can be
thought when we do have a cure for their
cause of death or as seen in many
fiction films there is the idea of using
cry preservation or cryosleep for long
duration space travel
so that's the motivation but there are
some challenges you see when I decide to
Source themselves not all of them
survive the process and that's not my
fault well maybe to some extent it is
but that's just because the way we
freeze it and the way we thought them
isn't 100 effective
so why does that happen well as we lower
the temperature the water outside the
cell starts to freeze as that starts to
freeze it reduces the water
concentration and increases the
concentration of solutes this then draws
extra water out of the cell through
osmosis causing the cell to become
dehydrated crystals may also form inside
the cell
and so to circumvent this we use
so-called cryoprotective agents
two standard cryoprotective agents that
are used are DMSO and glycerol with DMSO
famously being used for storing skin
but it's not just about the use of crowd
protective agents it's also about the
speed of the calling how fast is it
as different cell types have different
optimal thresholds the whole rationale
behind query protective agents is to
prevent ice crystals from forming and
one way of doing that is through
vitrification the process of changing a
liquid into a hard substance that
doesn't contain crystals
here this works by adding a high
concentration of cryo protectants and
ice blockers to water and cooling the
sample really fast so fast it becomes a
glass
side job done well not really while
these cryo protectants and calling
strategies have some efficacy there is
firstly the problem with freezing Beyond
cells such as organs where you have
different cell types different sizes and
so it's hard to freeze all parts evenly
and then these cases with organs
sometimes you can't really afford to
lose that many cells unlike me trying to
freeze a file of cells that's at all
identical where I could you know I could
lose a few because I'll get them back
which brings us on to the second sort of
major problem which is the fact that
it's not just about freezing the samples
it's also about warming the samples back
up again because during warming eyes
re-crystallization kind of car where ice
crystals can grow and cause mechanical
damage and cellulitis
so how can we improve this process to
minimize the damage and both the rapid
cooling and the thawing
well one location where we can get some
lessons potentially is from looking at
model organisms you see model organisms
oh well just other organisms that aren't
ourselves though with the cold in
different ways
option number one migrate to warmer
places
or the nippy era I'm just saying how do
we know it's a night page because of all
the ice
well things just got a little chillier
probably not that useful in this case
two anhydrobiosis drying out
nice potentially not that effective when
it comes to cryogenics three freeze
avoidance strategies or actually
cellular freeze tolerance strategies
like this wood frog hair it can endure
freezing of up to 70 of its total body
water in winter months and thought
within hours without experiencing any
measurable change when Frozen the wood
frogs show no cardiac or lung activity
brain function or physical movements but
all of these capabilities are restored
upon thawing sounds like we should be
investigating the wood frog
so how much words would the word frog
frog if a wood frog could frog words
well there is some research that's been
done into these wood frogs and one way
that they prepare is that they increase
the amounts of glycogen storage in late
fall to serve as an internal fuel during
freezing and they modify their membrane
structure to prevent cellular claps
inducing a strong antioxidant response
to combat oxidative damage and most
importantly they reduce their overall
metabolism to strategically utilize the
stored energy only for pro survival
processes
the question still is well how do they
trigger it how do they get it all
regulated
but they're not the only species we can
look at
we can also look at the ladybugs it's
super cools without freezing
water in the ladybug remains liquid at
-19 degrees apparently the way they do
it is by making anti-freeze chemicals or
ice blockers so potentially nature
already has answers that we can exploit
to be able to improve our
cryopreservation strategies
for example one species definitely worth
further investigating are the Arctic
Scrolls they are the largest animals
known to super cool and the reason that
obviously large animals it's harder to
super cool is the fact that one thing
you want to do is prevent ice crystals
from forming and ice crystals can form
in the presence of so-called nucleators
that help all the water molecules line
up so these are things like bits of dust
bits of foods and bacteria which
obviously the bigger you are the more
nucleators you have about
so they ask a bit of a problem
but this also links on to hibernation
which the Arctic Scrolls also undergo
where hibernation triggers The Slowdown
of their metabolism but not only should
we be investigating then how these
different species hibernate or what
triggers their slowing down of
metabolism but we also should probably
work out what makes the hibernating
animals wake up for another interesting
thing to think about is what happens
following the hibernation or this period
of cooling
and one thing that people were intrigued
about was whether or not the Arctic
ground squirrels retains their long-term
memory after this hibernation
because during hibernation blood flow to
the brain and metabolism is greatly
reduced and there are also changes to
the length and branching of the
dendrites
well so far the data suggests that there
is an impact there is some evidence that
it reduced their recall and amazed
navigation tasks compared to squirrels
that didn't hibernate
but it didn't affect their ability to
discriminate Familia from unfamiliar
individuals but this is hibernation a
study came out in 2015 that shows
persistence of long-term memory in
fitrified and revised worms
although that said this opposing refue
rights the results of the study on
nematode worms are a far cry from
providing any evidence that human memory
can be preserved post-fitrification
and so before I think I agree with this
so far there really does seem to be a
lack of evidence
so what else is going on in the space at
the moment well in 2015 the brain of a
small rabbit was frozen and it was
recovered in near perfect condition and
according to a press release it is the
first demonstration that near perfect
long-term structural preservation of an
intact mammalian brain is achievable
but preservation of the brain again is
No Way indicates that all psychological
functions remain intact
so ultimately I think until we have an
agreement on the molecular entity
structure slash phenomenon of what
memory storage and brain function really
is I don't think it is easy to unfair
whether memory would be preserved so
that's what's going on in the space and
speaking of a space space and space
travel
science fiction has often featured the
whole body freezing of humans to sustain
them over long space flight durations
and so this is what I was talking about
earlier with cryogenics where according
to my favorite book cryogenics is the
word for freezing whole people in hopes
that they can be revived someday
but my favorite book was a little bit
less optimistic
no matter how carefully they were frozen
almost every part of them will be
damaged by ice or crying protectants
even if they do wake up they will need
repairs to almost every body part
but while my favorite book ended
negatively I thought it would be better
to end positively as there are different
companies in this space that are looking
to develop the technology further and
make cryogenics a fireball option for
different patients
for humans and pets firstly there is
Alcor a company that's been going for
over 50 years and they have lots of
information on their website about it
then there's a more recent company
tomorrow by stasis which similarly to
Alcor are offering a complete cryogenic
service but here they also have two
companion organizations one being the
European biostasis Foundation as West
nonprofit Foundation dedicated to
furthering biostasis by conducting
scientific research
and because I have a part I have to
mention cryopets another recent startup
that is developing whole body cry
preservation for pets that down the line
May pivots do the same of humans
essays to provide a more optimistic
right now
whatever they were taken whether through
better comprehension of basic phenomena
or an exploitation of Nature's
empiricism most of cryobiology's real
achievements lie ahead
however as always in research they
frequently forgotten the most important
tools to this end will not be just new
sophisticated techniques and instruments
but a determination to aggressively
maintain an open mind to avoid the
tunnel vision of a favorite hypothesis
and to enjoy as a consequence the vital
capacity to stay in motion
so your apology is definitely a
multi-disciplinary topic requiring an
understanding of biology
chemistry for the deployment and
production of cryo protectants
physics for understanding the energetics
of ice crystallization and controlling
ice growth and Engineering to Material
Sciences
but what are people's actual opinions on
cryopreservation
while around 20 of people in the study
showed interest in signing up for
cryopreservation
a much smaller fraction decided to be
query preserved around six percent
moreover many respondents around 42 were
pessimistic regarding the likelihood of
cryopreservation being successful with
the mean estimate of time until Revival
of Craig reserved bodies would be
possible was 82 years
but given what I've told you one
question remains would you want to be
query observed
so on that bombshell I hope you've
learned something and it's pretty
intensive introduction to cryobiology
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening